hey guys Dr. Berg here in this video we're going
to talk about how to read your cholesterol okay so
what's the function of cholesterol well it acts
as a cell membrane coding so every single cell
in the body every single cell has a coating of
cholesterol so we need that all the outside of
your skin has a cholesterol layer cholesterol
is needed to make hormones specifically stress
hormones in certain other hormones for
anti-inflammation also it's involved in
brain activity and so when you don't have enough
cholesterol it can affect your memory and that's
why one of the side effects of statin drugs which
lower the cholesterol is memory loss okay there's
many other functions but those are the top three
big functions okay cholesterol is also needed to
make vitamin D it's also needed to make bile B il
e to actually help you dissolve fats now what's
funny to me is that you know we talk about
good and bad cholesterol like HDL is called
good cholesterol you can kind of think of the
H is like a healthy cholesterol and then LDL is
supposed to the bad cholesterol like if there's
two types of cholesterol but there's really no
such thing as two different types of cholesterol
it's really one cholesterol that's inside of both
of these little guys this stands for high density
lipoproteins okay this is low-density lipoproteins
do you notice I didn't say cholesterol in order
to transport cholesterol which it doesn't mix
well with water or blood you have to put it in a
protein capsule and that's what these are these
are little tiny shuttles that deliver cholesterol
in certain directions in the body so let's talk
about like let's talk about the LDL first so we
have this outer covering of this protein okay
that surrounds the cholesterol and the purpose
of the LDL is to transport the cholesterol from
your gut and liver to your intestinal tract and
then write to the blood so basically LDL takes
the cholesterol from the liver in the blood
and then from the blood it goes to the rest
of the tissues okay that's what LDL does now HDL
takes the excess cholesterol that the LDL put in
there and removes it and brings it back to the
liver and then the liver can actually dismantle
it and take care of it so basically we have this
exchange between cholesterol coming out of the
liver right here and cholesterol going into the
liver and we need that balance so when you see
that you have high levels of bad cholesterol you
know doctors instantly give you a drug to shut it
down but what I want to do is I'm going to teach
you what's behind that like what's causing that
problem we want to use this as a little indicator
light to tell us that there's some problem inside
a body normally the LDL should be below 130 now in
2004 a group of 15 doctors panels of doctors that
basically decided to lower the LDL to 102 even
as low as 70 for certain people that are risk
factors okay so what they did is they adjusted
the numbers they changed the normal values and
put 8 million people on cholesterol medication
overnight that's what they did well then we
find out and I put a link down there that a lot of
these doctors had ties to the drug companies yeah
I know surprise right so unfortunately people are
freaked out about if that LDL is too high and so
we'll get more into that but basically that's what
it does so LDL takes the cholesterol and drives it
into the the blood and then out to the tissues
and then HDL takes the excess cleans it up and
puts it back into the liver a normal HDL is in
a male body should be at 40 or greater okay and
a female body at 47 or greater now let's talk
first about let's talk about triglycerides for
a second what is triglycerides those basically
those are blood fats and basic 5 glycerides are
converted sugars okay so triglycerides are used to
transport excess carbohydrates so if you have high
triglycerides I know for a fact you have too much
sugar in your body because the hormone insulin is
the converting hormone that makes triglycerides
high so we want about 150 or less that's the value
petrol glyceride so we don't want them greater
than 150 it's very easy to get to change this
and it's simply by getting rid of sugar out of the
diet now they also talked about total cholesterol
to HDL ratios and all these different calculations
I don't like that I like the triglyceride to HDL
ratio the best this will give the best indicator
of your risk for heart disease and basically you
just divide your total cholesterol by I'm sorry
total triglycerides by the HDL and that gives
you the ratio and if it's greater than 6 there's
a problem if it's 2 or less it's good so we want
it to be lower okay so that's kind of a ratio
you can look at but really in reality there's
really no such thing as good or bad cholesterol it
just because you need cholesterol you cannot live
without cholesterol you just want the exchange
there I would say about 99.99% of the time just
by cleaning up the sugar the carbs the bread the
pasta the alcohol you can clean this up so fast
and bring it back to normal ranges ok there are
genetic cholesterol issues but it's very rare
it's not as common as you think but if you do have
a genetic tendency to have high cholesterol even
if you had 350 this studies showed that there's
still no risk for heart disease so the so for
them to put you on statins right away is a big
mistake because there's no study that shows that
it's actually going to create a problem for you
especially if these other things are working fine
in fact I never ever look at total cholesterol
as anything I ignore the total cholesterol and
because they did drop that down to 200 used to be
like 225 but even if it's like 350 if it's less
than 350 I'm not going to worry about if these
other things are working fine and it's very rare
for it to go up if you're off sugars usually it'll
come right down the other point I want to make is
that 75% of the cholesterol in your body right now
is made by your own body it's made by your liver
and the cells you liver makes 2,000 milligrams of
cholesterol every single day and the rest of the
cells make a thousand milligrams and only 25% of
the cholesterol in your body comes from diet okay
the rest comes from your body making it so that
might shift your viewpoint because if you eat less
your body makes more if you eat more your body
makes less because we have this feedback mechanism
so I just want to kind of cover some of these
basics and kind of give you the simplicity of what
it is so you're not freaked out about it but for
people to be put on medication when they should be
working like this is what most people do if it's
high they go in a low-fat diet it's usually high
carbs they go on medication to go and exercise
that they never cut out the sugar okay all right
so go ahead and apply this information make
it put your comments below thanks for watching